what I've what I've learned since the
death of my aunt is that she touched
many her assassination says two little
girls or little boys don't speak up keep
your mouth shut
that the Custis was my aunt she was this
voice this force that had to be reckoned
with
she was an indigenous rights leader and
she was a moral leader beyond reproach
beyond any of the other leaders in
Ontario's and that's why they had to
take her down
but police are corrupt the government's
corrupt and the entire country is owned
by 10 to 15 families how can impoverish
people of a country survive this was why
I think they was fighting this was why
indigenous people have ended us were
fighting
after 2009 the underand government was
told okay you've had your coup now you
have to behave and you have to keep the
country stable because our military
interests are at stake that was the word
from the United States
you have the militarization of the
police you have corruption among the
government and that's why you have 110
activists environmental activists
murdered with impunity
I was with Beth DITA in 2009 during the
coup I asked her the question why do you
do this and she said because we can't
look like this no one should have to
live like this